(mid-tempo guitar music)
- Today we are doing
a pancake competition.
- I've never done any kind of
baking competition with each other.
- So we decided we're gonna
try to make each other's faces.
- We are going to be
competing on who can make
the tastiest, most creative pancake.
- And when we're done,
we're gonna send a picture
to a friend or two.
- We're gonna text our friend Kristin,
to see which pancake she likes better.
- To make it a little more
spicy, or weight or something.
If I win, she's gonna rub my feety-feets.
- And if I win, I want
a full body massage.
- This is a good game when you're tired
of getting along with the
person that you're dating.
- Okay, so here we are.
- We have all of our ingredients here.
- We have fruit, blueberries,
strawberries, bananas.
- Chocolate syrup for my
chocolate baby. (both laugh)
- It's good to make sure
that your man is comfortable
with the fact that you're
better at things than he is.
- Oh, you can calm down on the drink.
- I am feeling so free right now.
- Don't be looking, or peeking.
- Don't look.
Is she looking?
You'll know if she's
looking, don't let her look.
- Spice up my pancake, ahh!
- Was the final touch it needed.
- I mean, if I'm a senior
citizen, he's going great.
- This is Mickey Mouse's cousin,
Mo Mouse.
- I'm almost done, I just
have one finishing touch.
- Ready to show me what you got first.
- Turn and receive your pancake.
- Yes, I'm so excited!
- Why are you excited
about that? What the sh--
- Because I--
- Oh my God, she made a dick!
- I knew it!
I knew that you were gonna make a penis.
(laughing)
(stammers) You're gonna
be crude and disgusting
and make a dick, I'm gonna
make a bigger dick than you.
- I'm finished.
This is, well, this is a woman.
You see this is a movie star.
This is Charlize Theron.
- Ta da! He's done.
Big glasses, cute little ears.
- I should see a doctor if, that's weird.
- Yeah, you might have a UTI...
- Oh, babe, do guys get UTIs?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Man] Oh.
- Are friends are definitely
gonna like this better.
- Well, we'll see.
- So, I'm taking pictures and sending this
to our friend Kristin,
and she's going to judge
and let us know who's the winner.
- So the friend doesn't
know who did which one.
I said, "which one do you like better?
"Photo one or photo two?"
- We haven't heard back from Lisa yet,
so, she's always late.
- Yeah, Kyle responded,
he's the first response.
"Hmm, I wanna say (laughs)
- What? Read it out
loud, read it out loud!
(laughs)
Read it out loud!
- "Hmm, I wanna say the top one,
"but them titties is nice, gonna say top."
He still voted...
- Which is mine!
- [Man] He still voted the top one.
Which is mine.
- [Man] Why even mention it?
- She just got back to me.
F*$k!
- [Woman] The first one is
my fav--
- [Man] F*$k!
- I was the first one.
(man groans)
- Okay, it's Lisa.
(laughs) Okay.
Well, Lisa has voted and
she thinks that this pancake
makes her lose her appetite.
- [Man] What??
- [Woman] Yes!!
- It's a super fun game,
you can win a bond.
- Yeah, well, I'm out 20 bucks.
- You know, in the end, I'm
just going to enjoy eating
half of his pancake,
cause it looks delicious.
I think really we're both winners.
- Full body massage!
(man stammers)
Head-to-toe massage.
- Enjoy the pancakes, guys.
- You ready to eat dick?
(man laughs)
- To Sunday fun day!
- [Red shirt man] Cheers!
- Cheers, cheers!
- [Voiceover] Are you guys
actually gonna eat the pancakes?
- Yeah.
- It's okay, babe.
- You got syrup on your face.